hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Crash Bandicoot
we're gonna go right back into it
because I don't have time to sit around
and mull over my fate
I have to go charging in blindly into
the madness and carry on and this might
be a boss fight I have no idea but it
wouldn't make sense if it was a boss
fight would it oh it is a boss fight hi
hey what you're not even gonna explain
yourself how do you explain yourself who
do you have to say for yourself big guy
oh hi okay yeah whatever oh wait are you
not a boss oh you're not that's why you
didn't yeah you're right get out of here
with your Rubina s' oh you think you got
me worried for a second there I still
think that you could sorry
aha oh no your barrels love you so pups
they just disappeared when you died
alright booga-booga here we go yeah okay
well thank you for being here with me
for this momentary adventure I'll never
forget the toughest with shared mr.
masked man
oh I'll weave those for posterity okay
do we have another guy oh are you mad
just cuz I killed your brother
oh man I've killed many a siblings and
this came apparently okay bye then
oh that poor pig that had to see its
whole family died yeah and if again
you're confused I'll put a link to the
live stream that I did is two hours of
this and I got mad hey hidey-hidey-ho
[Music]
well this one isn't so bad I gotta admit
this one actually is kind of relaxing
with all that the glorious loveliness
that it is oh your barrel went back ah
so polite even after death you put
things away alright
oh we done rolling barrels is there no
one left alive to roll barrows whoa I
don't like that it's donkey kong up in
here
timeyou ones last yeah wasn't what did I
hit a checkpoint I have no idea I'll
excuse you what I don't know what
happened I don't like it though I do not
know I do not care that was not cool
whatever happened there Oh
cuz I like slid off and then I
recalibrated wrong okay I don't know how
to deal with the bouncy booze I think
the bouncy boobs are just hell on earth
okay here comes a bouncy boo but I can
beat it there okay we're just gonna oh
boy do i I guess ah oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no no oh I made it I survived that
I don't know how I don't know when Oh
God oh I got smooshed I don't like this
no wonder they gave me so many lives
leading up to this I'm gonna need them
alright this key see everything bad
happens immediately after I go hey this
isn't so bad I could get used to this
one it's kind of relaxing jumping over
barrels Oh God oh he thinks that it's
also probably not a good idea to be
tossing toxic barrels that way one
handling them is bad but also - yeah
[ __ ]
oh boy no okay run run run run Oh God
hey oh man I don't know how I made that
I don't know how I made that fire those
extra bouncy oh boy key okay Jimmy that
checkpoint please yes thank you I don't
know why that one was there by itself
single want buffer for me no no no no no
no where are you going
ah miss me by that much no okay made
that get in that okay well I'm gonna
stop using the directional pad because
oh no it's it's not good for me oh maybe
here just a little bit I didn't know
that would be that ends the way I didn't
anticipate that I didn't anticipate it
so you got a hurry cuz otherwise you're
gonna be father knocking bond okay we
did it I think at least we got live
somewhere out here
you guys have never been flubber nucking
boned before yeah I didn't think okay
we're fine
oh yes okay I got your number Oh Rick
got it from Steve okay
don't even sponsz it over my head okay
yes thank you hey I got I got all of
them did I actually get all the box
nearly perfect but you died don't give
me that look tip because you died and
you had a clone come back Oh mr.
judgmental Bandicoot
oh I'm sorry with your blue pants and
purple hue and tapping foot in 2012
markiplier hair [ __ ] you okay carrying
on okay jeez all that just to get
through oh no pinstripe pataw row
okay this is pinstriper toro his tommy
gun isn't always reliable well ain't
that the truth
how many time the shoot on that guy I
think this chair would be able to stop
this Hey
alright how do i oh this is a
straight-up fight II fight ok - I don't
think it's very fair considering you
have bullets and I have hopes and dreams
oh did you catch me with a ricochet did
your devilish good looks get me okay if
I jump straight into the line of fire
that doesn't do me too good [ __ ] no oh
you are pretty accurate with that who'd
have thought that I wouldn't be able to
dodge bullets God the [ __ ] mouth god
damn he's good he's real good
no it's fun what didn't you die yeah I
got a jump on his head probably that's
probably what I got it don't give me
that [ __ ] I don't need you I need
you desperately okay well I don't know
what's going on
okay I was I started this adventure
great and I had a lot of fun and now it
seems like I'm being blown oh I don't
understand that okay I got this ever you
didn't see anything else I didn't
actually put in any other attempts there
so it's all why okay I got you so you
gotta get him on the reloads easy peasy
lemon squeeze him got more yeah that's
right good thing this chair is extremely
strong got him
okay hiding hiding hiding hiding hiding
hiding being patient is real fun
thank you really lames like me why did
that not get him alright alright I got
this
I got your number okay so I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna panic I'm not panicking
about nothing from nobody cuz I I know
how to deal oh yeah I didn't make it
didn't make it didn't make it oh hey got
him okay
Goti okay you think he'd be smart enough
to come around the other side of this
chair chairs always been for me though
always been there for me alright one
more do dance
hahahaha get ready oh come on
this guy's good guys real good hey I did
it
oh he dead pinstripe to e meaning that I
kill the man everything's great
I think that's what that means we made
it through that without too much tears
and and me sobbing like a little baby
but that's okay we got a lot more to go
oh why but why though what is this magic
Oh black magic woman where am I going
I found a bone neighs I found the ponies
I gots electrolyze it wouldn't have done
that okay I've been told I've been told
you oh that's handy oh that's handy
dandy oh that is handy dandy okay it's
gotta be careful about it
oh boy okay
so this parts not that bad I'm only
gonna you know what walking on the rope
is for chumps that seems Chiti and I'm
not a cheater so that's what I'm gonna
do today oh god I hate hi piggy Pig okay
that's where you're gonna go you know
before you didn't go that far so it
didn't make me think anything of it I'm
gonna forget those boxes I don't I don't
care about completionist at this point
okay
this is gonna be one of those oh okay I
just kept going forward then whatever
god I didn't want to go forward but I
just kept going forward how about that
how about that okay all right that's
that's this is your stop is it turtle
turtle Betty Betty I'll need you but I
needed you and you let me down I'm
tempted to run on that rope but it's
it's cheating it's cheating it's
cheating it's cheating oh boy
god damn at you know okay you stay there
then I guess that's what's happening
here
so they just stay once you go over them
that's awfully not yet oh my god I'm
getting flustered okay no yep okay okay
no good that's worth the time it really
is Oh fine why why am i timing it wait
wouldn't do I'm an idiot
why would I time that I would just run
forward at the right time no that's that
was the wrong time
I'm not gonna run on the ropes
what oh so now I have info it doesn't
matter when I fall you know what I mean
oh you made me faster okay sure you're
gone now yeah see what I don't know why
I was doing that when I could just do oh
come on I'm getting all kinds of
flustered this is now it should be oh
yeah you just get out of sitting off in
the distance over there don't think I
didn't see that out of the corner ma ha
ha ok but this is what I meant why don't
I just do this and then I'd go the
distance that I need to go okay
no I saw that you piece of [ __ ]
Wow jeezum I saw that everyone saw that
oh you cheating bastard oh my god oh
this is gonna give me this is gonna get
me hi friend I'll be on my way then
there's starin breathin right into my
nose ah
that was lovely I didn't jump on the
rope the Cheney Wang I'm a cheater
look at me look at me oh come on
hi again hi how are you I'm great
good to hear that thank you for being
you you're so lovely and everything all
right here don't worry I'm not quitting
just carrying a load of the next episode
you're gonna pick it up right where I
left off in the middle of madness but I
need to go calm down so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know how I'm doing down the comments
below I know there's painful painful for
me too so thanks again everybody for
watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
me